so people are doing this from different
aspects we just found a gap for people
who lost use of their hands they're not
paralyzed to a chair they they can move
around all day um
and you know and they just want to use
not only that one device but a variety
of devices all day for communication
education and play
and that's what we decided to focus on
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
honored to be hosting miri berger here
at google for startups talking about
how we can leverage technology to bring
mobility and fine motor skills to people
who may have lost them
miri is the founder and ceo of six
degrees she is an industrial designer by
training completed a master's degree
from the pratt institute and a bfa in
ceramic design from the betsell academy
of arts she holds patents for her work
in design and has over 15 years of
experience in a wide variety of projects
in the fields of toys furniture
electronics and soft goods
millie specializes in designing products
that consider unconventional needs
materials and uses
welcome miley
miri burger welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being with me
today thank you so much for having me
over uh you're working on something so
special six degrees hey we're talking
about motion and we're talking about
smart motion the integration of the
physical and digital world
and making some pretty tremendous
positive impact on people that really
need it uh take me back a little bit to
who you are and how this sort of came up
for you five years ago when you
co-founded six degrees well um to
understand what happened five years ago
i normally start with the actual origin
story um i met my
husband at 19 while we were both serving
in the military
my husband got injured he's my husband
now i just met him then he had
gotten injured a month earlier a nerve
injury to his leg as a paratrooper
and um
as in coming from family physicians this
led to introducing him to a neurosurgeon
which led to physical therapy and
rehabilitation
which actually has never stopped
since
and as he found himself and i found
myself with him in rooms with other 18
to 22 year olds going through rehab
that got injured in their limbs their
hands or legs
we found that past physical pain the
second thing that hits you is loss of
independence
and it's it also stays with you
and that really
stayed with us uh emotionally uh
conceptually but also physically for him
um throughout our entire uh you know
life together
fast forward 15 years later we're
married we're both at school
i'm at pratt doing industrial design
he's at nyu running the innovation lab
and
we met it again with uh with a lecturer
uh who lost his dominant hand
and we really wanted um starting with
him but then it grew into a larger
population to connect people who lost
the use of their hands back to
communication technology
um and unemployment but to do that with
the guidance of independence wow so
that's how we kind of started six
degrees we both finished school five
around you know
uh five years ago um i was already
working in design consultancy we both
decided we want to do this in israel so
i left my job in in brooklyn um we took
our two kids and two pieces of suitcase
and uh came to israel and started the
company incredible incredible and so
we're talking about people with
disabilities or with lack of mobility in
their upper limbs being able to be
independent that that is the the basic
premise so how does technology
um
provide any support here what are some
of the some of the ways that we can
leverage technology to do that
yeah so um and i'll start with with what
we do but i can obviously zoom out um to
what's going on in the ecosystem um so
we started with people who lost their
fine motor skills this means they can't
use their hands because of injury
paralysis or disease um normally focused
on finger motion finger movement um
and
this affects you know how you use a
mouse how you would tap a touch screen
how you
play a game with a controller and so on
let's say on xbox
and so what we wanted to do is to take
the output meaning the command on the
side of the device
but replace the action with motion so
instead of you clicking a mouse you
would move your uh arm you you can twist
it make a whipping motion a fist bump
um or lift your shoulder and that'll
correspond to the computer as a click
or to the phone as a tap and so on and
so
we also decided to do this focusing on
individual motion because as you know
everyone's unique um
to quantify it a little more we started
out by putting 30 people with no
mobility issues in a room and asked them
to put on the device to gather data and
to do the same motion and the
commonality between them that was less
than 30 percent meaning wow people are
vastly different in the way that they
move it even in micro emotions
and so we knew that we had to develop a
technology or an algorithm to kind of
accommodate to that and let everybody
use their existing emotion their
existing ability not looking at the
disability but looking at what you can
do
in order to to get back to using the
digital world incredible and um and
talking about the ecosystem
uh what's going on is a lot of people
are doing this from different aspects so
that means if you can move your eyes uh
you know technology developed sure
tracks your eyes and and uses that as a
guidance for control if you can move
your head it's the same thing there are
technologies that focus on muscle
potential meaning you make them uh you
you flex your muscle and that sends a
little electrical pulse
uh further or cameras that we all we all
experience that through we tracking your
body shape and so on so people are doing
this from different aspects we just
found a gap for people who lost use of
their hands they're not
paralyzed to a chair they could move
around all day um
and you know and they just want to use
not only that one device but a variety
of devices all day for communication
education and play
and that's what we decided to focus on
and we're probably a little
underestimating as a society that the
role of fine motor skills especially
with our hands right we we constantly
talk about opposable thumbs as sort of
the
the burn butter of what differentiates
us and uh but i think we underestimate
what happens when you lose that fine
motor skill right it's not just if
you're in a wheelchair that you have
that you're lacking independence but
it's but but it's something like that so
so what is what is the product that six
degrees is working on to tackle this
yeah um so thanks for the question so we
basically we developed a product called
my move uh which is a off-the-shelf
hardware meaning it the same technology
exists in other smart watches that you
know today or in phones
but the this hardware in our product
is is layered with an algorithm that
looks at motion so basically you can
take my move it looks kind of like a a
wearable generic wearable
smart watch
you can place it on your wrist and the
watch area on the upper arm or on your
leg so basically any limb that can move
and it asks we asked you to do a five
minute onboarding uh through playing a
game
five minutes five minutes
uh we start out by asking where you
place the device then we ask you to put
turn on bluetooth so you can connect it
to
the computer phone tablet
um then we ask you to play a five minute
game um and throughout that five minute
game we look at your motion range
ability speed accuracy whether you have
involuntary motion like tremor in other
words we just ask you to stay still and
see what that looks like um
and
through that we kind of build a library
of
basically 720 different aspects of the
way that you move wow
and we do that in
80 samples a second meeting really
really fast so every time you move or
don't move we add that to the algorithm
and that teaches the algorithm about you
specifically
after that five minutes you can now take
that bluetooth connection with no
program installed no um
extra
uh hardware like a dongle
uh or camera you just turn on your
bluetooth find the my move device on
that
on on your bluetooth computer phone
tablet and connect and you can start
going and so at that moment you were
able to effectively
exert find fine motor skills on your
smart device without actually exerting
fi if you know fine motor skills on the
device yeah from that moment on uh we
take the motion that you chose uh as a
command uh you can think of it as a
gesture sure um and we
and that gesture is going to be an
action on the on the corresponding
device so if you chose let's say a fist
bump motion then that fist bump will be
a right click or left click on your
computer it'll also be a tap
or swipe on your phone or it can be the
x button or the y button on your
controller gaming controller and you
moving right left left up and down the
way that you do sure uh will be the
corresponding motion sorry of
of the mouse moving on the screen or the
cursor i mean moving on the screen
or uh or the um joystick that you would
use on a gaming controller um and then
you can basically use that to get back
to full function
and so i so now i understand the
importance of the
of the precision that you were talking
about before the training the model
specifically from your own actions that
feeds itself and to be able to be to be
have very precise identification of what
gestures you're making because it's very
easy to confuse this with this right
yeah
and so you want to make sure that you're
getting exactly right because that could
be the difference of sending the email
or not sending the email and you know in
our cases sure
now
when you talk to me a little bit about
the creation of the product i'm always
really curious about those types of
things with hardware the physical world
how do you even approach
a process like this as a designer
yourself how do you how do you think
through
building the product from the consumer's
perspective their experience
their market education that needs to
come to this i love to hear it all
so uh obviously this is an uh iterate
iterative process um it was learn uh
correct repeat uh and and and so on
throughout the lifetime of the company
uh but i'm a really big believer and
inclusion by design and so we started
out picking uh the ends of the spectrum
meaning people who can move too much or
too little uh as the models for for the
algorithm for the technology uh and we
know that through designing for the for
those uh ends we cover the middle and
we started out by thinking of really
simple things like how to use your phone
you use it
lying down sitting up walking on a train
and if you think of say
the thing that reads speed on your phone
the accelerometer
um then if you're wearing something with
an accelerometer and you're on you're in
a car or train that comes into effect
um let's say uh camera devices that you
know today the wii doesn't really
capture you lying down on the bed and
you know chilling uh so we really
started thinking about you know where
people would use this device throughout
the day
um and then we asked them to use it
which is the
obvious next step but you see a lot of
technologies being developed and kind of
when they're done
the user comes in i think it's really
important to have that iterative process
with the user right in the beginning
i always call our users the the company
employee that you never meet in the
office because they're really really
important their feedback their input
is really critical to get a good um you
know technology or product out there
what was was the process sort of trivial
from a planning perspective i mean did
you
sort of understand the problem because
you've you've had those personal
experiences and you were subjected to
them so you understood a little bit
where the pain points were and how and
how you built the confidence because
part of it is not just
regaining those skills but also
regaining the confidence that you can't
have those fine motor skills especially
on you know on on these things that that
are generally we think of them as very
very fast quick paced actions
yeah i mean that's a great question i
would love to say i planned everything
in the beginning but that would be
incorrect i um
we actually started as i said making
this product for one individual this
individual had an amputation below the
elbow
and was wearing a prosthetic
and we started out by
looking at the user as someone who wears
a prosthetic and this individual was
also
a cad designer a computer modeling um
expert a teacher
and so we wanted to have this function
in cad in a computer
um
and then as we asked other wounded
veterans uh in the us as well as uh
wounded veterans in israel if they want
to try it they they said well i have a
friend with ms i have a uh an aunt who
has tremor
i have uh you know a cousin that has
nerve injury and can't really put
anything on their skin can we put this
on clothing and so every question so it
started out by looking at a problem and
trying to to adapt a solution
and then
that solution kind of grew into
um you know
uh an ad hoc sorry an at request
um
development so
we wanted to help as many people as
possible so we were looking at you know
when we when someone came with tremor
we're like that's great we can add this
aspect to the algorithm and have them
read the tremor and see how that works
and so it was an evolving process
how do you decide
you know what where to go from here with
six degrees i mean there's so many
different things that you can do right
how how do you sort of think through the
prioritization or the rationalization of
what are the right features to be
building out or the right products then
the next might move if you will to be
built out what is what does this process
for you look like
yeah so i mean until this point i kind
of focused on technology but i think um
once you when you're building a company
you have to also take the business
aspect and the vision or the mission
into account so
in our case uh our vision and mission
was to start out uh by
including
uh the the people that we service people
lost our fine motor skills or dexterity
um throughout you know throughout their
accommodating their use of technology
throughout the day that could be
when they're using their media console
and a car
it could be when they're using their
smart devices to communicate that could
be at work
it could be in a presentation and it
could be in a variety of aspects so i
think the first thing that we look at
when we cho when we choose
where to go next we're looking at our
population
secondly you have to look at the endgame
the vision
and for us it's for this technology or
this user experience to be embedded in
any wearable device so you don't need my
move you can take the algorithm embed it
in any smartwatch to allow anyone to do
this you don't have to have an injury
or a disability in order to use this and
i think that's part of having this
inclusive
that anyone is
you know is on a level playing field uh
so
so that is another guidance um and the
third is really uh
what is the path in order to accelerate
that uh you know these steps moving up
so
our path is
we start we just started uh selling my
move in april uh in the us focused
mainly but also in australia and brazil
and we i'm happy to say that we're
actually selling it to assistive
technology libraries to universities to
get um
you know students back to school or back
to sorry to education but also writing
their project and doing their graphics
by themselves
uh and we're selling it to corporates in
order to get employees not only with a
severe or visible
disability but also someone who can be a
programmer and suffers from carpal
tunnel syndrome and can go to work
because of that you know momentarily or
for a few months and so we started
hitting those verticals which are still
under the mission but um can grow the
company to the next stage so i'm hearing
that primarily from a go to market until
now there's a lot of different
businesses that are that are taking
interest in this for the different
people that are within whether it's
students in universities employees and
companies etc um
is there a specific reason why you found
that b2b is a is the strong approach
here now versus then going after the
consumer market because obviously
anybody that has fine motor issues they
they this is something that's hugely
relevant for them and also in their
daily lives not just in work
yeah and that's a great question for us
we looked at what other companies did um
and kind of uh put the weight the um
how fast this would you know reach the
end consumer or the end user
uh going through the company versus
going through the end user first
um and so we reached out to these
organizations the at programs the
businesses um the corporates i mean
and um
the ad programs the the businesses and
uh the
universities because they take care of
the financing they purchase the device
they give it to the end user to use for
a few months weeks days
and so on
or semesters
and so
in that case the the end user can try
this out risk free and really
gather the benefit and the value and we
see that as a starting point uh to grow
this so you can really it's kind it's a
new technology the market doesn't really
know about it right and we thought it
would be uh best for the end user not to
be the purchaser and not to pay for it
but only to gain the value
and it's important to say that it's not
only for the end user it's also for
their surrounding
family friends um you know their company
benefits from this the university
benefits from this because they access a
lot more people
so it's it's really you think of it as
like you know the drop but then the wave
that comes after
right now you mentioned that you and
your husband
sort of picked up your whole family
finish your jobs and came here to start
this
so it sounds like you had such a
deep and meaningful personal conviction
as to where you're going here
do you feel that in the day today
looking back do you feel the the the
what you were hoping to feel working on
this working on six degrees
i think having a startup is amazing uh
it doesn't mean that all of you should
go out and start one it's also very
difficult there are there are a lot of
adversities you keep learning new skills
and um basically facing new challenges
every single day
um obviously
everyone
faces challenges every day but um but in
the case of a startup you're facing a
challenge and you have to uh kind of
address how that challenge would affect
the the customers you sell to your
investors your employees yourself your
family
and you have to do that every kind of
minute every time that happens over and
over again
so on one hand it's difficult because of
the challenge and the other it's
rewarding uh because once somebody comes
with feedback and says you know um you
got me to this place or
uh you had me you know doing something
independently you reduced pain you took
a burden from from someone and you get
that you get those twinkles not every
day but every once in a while
and and you look at it and normally
comes in parallel to kind of a challenge
that you're tackling
and at that moment that challenge
becomes really miniature
um
it really reduces it to okay i'll great
i'll solve this so i can get the next
one um so for us an impact-based
business is is really
what we wanted to start and what we're
building um and i i love that
so it sounds like this this why that you
have is so strong that it just overcomes
a lot of these other challenges that you
mean in the day today
yeah it's it's kind of like
a you know beacon that you can follow um
and if you're
you know on one hand it keeps you
focused and you're vertical and your
business and on the other it keeps you
focused on why you're there doing it
because otherwise there's no really
reason to start a startup uh
yeah you you uh you basically you pay
someone to work so
so until a certain point so um and you
work many hours and um it's it's always
a cost a cost reward
kind of
scale uh because you're always losing
out on things but you're also gaining a
lot
incrementally you know i have your uh
on your website open and i have the
video rolling and it's just so cool
watching how people are are leveraging
you know very simple movements that from
what you said before are very unique to
them they're very precise to their own
interpretation of those movements and
those actions
and and they're able to do go anything
from
from photoshop a cat to open up a
browser to play
game to flip through a slideshow to edit
an image i edited it's just so cool and
i can only think about you know going
back to what you were mentioning before
realizing that right after
the disability itself it's the the
second hardest thing there is losing the
independence yeah that that this is
something that's not trivial right
losing independence now understand that
we're not able to do what we were doing
before and regaining autonomy at least
in the digital sphere which is where
most of our jobs are anyways today
i think that's a pretty pretty
incredible impact that you're making so
thank you thank you for the amazing work
and thank you very much for being here
thank you amelia this is a great journey
and i look forward to to continuing
following six degrees and i continue uh
looking forward to listening to this uh
and seeing where other people are
impacting the world thank you so much
for having me over thank you